ميزه الكتاب هذا لا يوجد في اي كتاب في
العالم لديه هذه الميزه
الكتب اللي تتحدث عن عن البترول
والطاقه دائما تركز على الجانب الاقتصادي
العرض والطالب وخلافه او الجانب السياسي
او تداخل ما بين السياسه والبترول مثلا لا
تجد احدا يتكلم بما فيه الكفايه ما فيه
التحليل الجيد عن دور الشخصيات الشخصيات
انا في وجهه نظري في هذا الكتاب انا لا
اعتقد ان دور الاقتصاد او السياسه وغيرها
لا مهمه ولكن الشخصيات لم تعطى همم دورها
الحقيقي واهميه التي تستحق ولذلك على ليس
الموضوع ولما تتكلم عن شخصيه القاده
سوانيا
ناظر على النعيم كما ذكرت او غيرهم من
اساء الدول
فهيق شخصيه
ما هي بسيطه ما هي بسيطه ابدا لماذا لانها
بسيطه الان يتعمل عوامل نفسيه
عوامل تاريخيه للشخص واهم من هذا كل
المعلومات التي يحصل عليها من الجوانب
المراكز الابحاث والدراسات حول قضيه ما
بتروليه وطريقه وطريقه وطريقه اييه تفسير
هذه المعلومه وتحليلها اضافه الى ذلك ان
الاعلام يلعب دور